the PGA tour in live golf have agreed to
merge this is like Coke and Pepsi
deciding to be one company and all the
golfers are finding out on Twitter just
like us the PGA Tour and live golf drama
has been some high level beef for the
past year it created a massive divide in
the golf Community but what brings
everyone in sports together at the end
of the day money this now means that
Phil Mickelson Brooks kepka Bryson to
Shambo and more will be back playing in
the PGA the PGA Tour live golf and DP
World Tour agreed to combine their
commercial businesses and rights and
make one big for-profit company live
golf is funded by Saudi Arabia public
investment fund which has been
attracting golfers by promising them
millions and millions of dollars and now
it's planning on dumping cash into this
new company with this new deal players
won't have problems reapplying for
memberships with the PGA Tour and DP
World Tour which was one of the major
problems that golfers were dealing with
before the merger